you've gone through a lot by this point
you've written an application with
separation of concerns in mind and
you've also added a completely
unexpected feature to it that is nothing
to sneeze at that's impressive now
Rockstar developers will offer write
code entirely in JavaScript with no
organizational libraries and that's what
we just did so seriously give yourself a
pat on the back it's impressive
sometimes though it is useful to use an
organizational framework or library to
give you the features you need without
needing to do a ton of work at the
beginning we'll learn how to use one of
them and what they name their octopus so
keep going keep the momentum up you're
doing great and there's some really fun
stuff coming up